ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata in occasione
del mese di giugno abbiamo pensato di
utilizzare la nostra prima ricetta per
celebrare questo mese del pride e quindi
fare una torta arcobaleno centro per
creare questa torta avremo bisogno di
colorante alimentare farina uova a tante
tante uova latte panna da montare e
zucchero a velo
come sempre che bisogna fare un
preparato per crepe edf posso dire una
cosa oggi mi sento sul pezzo questo
spirito di accettazione celebrativo
questa cosa per cui siamo uguali in
fondo non scappare da mi sbaglio è
quello che dicevano scappare dai miei
sguardi non possono inseguirti non
possono se no perché doveva scappare
esempio a scappare ho deciso questa
volta di utilizzare un altro tipo di
ricetta che apoteca me non pulire alla
sanders a sanna che può andar bene al e
di fame apro delle uova quante diceva
anno prima vanno delle uova bisogna fare
un sacco di crepe perché bisognerà
metterle una sopra l'altra facciamo che
ti richiamo ogni volta che vidi
cinquantina di internet o forse come
possono bastare che ci siamo dimenticati
giù bilanci e grembiule ok andare adesso
posso far vedere il quantitativo però è
poco
adesso mettiamo del latte non so quanto
ne mettiamo che si svolge con te è
capito non è che dobbiamo stare lì con
l'ansia di casa decreto appena detto non
dev'essere liquida si sta più che chiaro
mai quante parole miti to all interno di
un video cielo promessi un
g lasciamo riposare le crepe facciamo
un'analisi dei colori come dicevo queste
qui li ho presi su amazon e sono i tipi
diversi colori infatti un po di problemi
o degli aiuti da casa perché io devo
sceglierne in particolare e sono fuori
dell'arcobaleno sono ormai c'è tutto
quanto un discorso su quanti sono i
colori dell'arcobaleno della bandiera
lgbt sono un boato di più tricolore
volevo fare io è semplice è una torta
karin arcobaleno zza il primo è rosso
questo qui è molto rosso però sto
scarlatto il pd ergo questo è più scuro
e questo e per oncia do adesso andiamo
alla scelta dell'arancione
come quell'altro ho un'idea ragazzini
arancio nino però questa cosa di giocare
coi colori e finissima giallo limone e
lui verde mela verde brancamenta bar da
branca vampa royal blue o un po di paura
peggio che non lo faccia apposta
questo quindi ora in mano io a
sensazione preferisco in rosa ricavi
inter più bello
l'unica cosa che però vorrei fare è
giusto per essere sicuri e e mischia
mischiare il rosso
berna un rosso agata e non so se un
agente una cosa diversa è un po di
bollino di ragazzi
ok io ragazzi sono veramente tanto
daltonico gli occhi mi stanno mandando a
fare in quante ne vogliamo fare di
ognuno di ogni colore ne facciamo di
crepe che io non ho paura di osare e
tutto è un pochino qua no quello un
colino ragazzi
vabbè andiamo a occhio mezzo bicchiere è
un miracolo questo è troppo maggio reti
che dobbiamo fare tante crepe una sopra
l'altra di colore diverso vuole fare una
riunione del pazzo ma vanno bene anche
per colore siamo sicuri di tanto nessuno
poi di cucina ste cose e famose prendono
per anni e divide in quanto a che fare
ma la mamma mia guarda che cosa hai
fatto
ma come faccia non c'è un corpino
soprattutto mamma mia è un altro
pezzetto quasi kakà come ieri corn e
ricordate che era stato bravissimo la
scorsa volta ma non mi sento altrettanto
bravo stavolta colorate era camicia in
tv sono la portata in coppa pasta
questa è bella e adesso l'arancione
tutto con il pesca per quella quando che
quando abbiamo fatto che il pana scorsa
volta
secondo me hai sbagliato le doti quindi
seguite le doti della provino e anche la
tecnica dell'altro video bello questo
però alcune però ti posso dire una cosa
è bello così non deve essere sempre
perfetto per essere perfetto in caspita
questo è poco giallo ok andiamo colverde
essere pronti per us in via giovanni
conti genoa pasticceria questo e finizio
bello e all'estero di un'acqua rally del
corallo e quello che per senso dopo
momento quello del colorante ripaga poi
la ripaga la cottura si è vero si devono
pure raffreddare perché so che smontano
la panna terzi a padova sul dire cioè
che
non è mai voluto bene no no no è che
indiretta cioè si stanno vedendo
anzi può inquadrare un secondo le
facciamo salutare tutte le persone alla
sconti per tentare della rega abbiamo
finito di cucinare le varie crepe nel
frattempo montiamo la panna montata la
nutella
non vogliamo dirvi qual è il nostro
segreto
mettiamo sciogliere la dalla bagnomaria
che vedranno una felicità pazzesca
primo cerchio
forse avrei dovuto montarla un pochino
di più così tanto è difficilissimo poi
viaggia si muove è una situazione
veramente brutta a dover andare avanti
nonostante tu veda la disfatta capito
[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
come si è totalmente fuori ma sta
viaggiando è tornata e tornata di
mellana meglio la panna perché così è
tutta storta è grazie non ti ispira come
non si stira ok ora vi faccio vedere da
grandi l'accaduto che non me la rube in
pasticceria giulia poi uscire
gentilmente è arrivata la mossa sun
della sanna prendiamo e creiamo una
specie di nuvola qui ritiro fuori
coloranti c'è il genio
io confido nell'opera binario qualcuno
che ha capito
ok siamo pronti
[Applauso]
[Risate]
forse sì forse meglio toglierlo ma non
ha messo il colorante no carina e
ragazzi
io suggerisco sinceramente di buttarci
un po di nutella
passiamo agli assaggi ragazzi venite qui
dai gianni non uno di meno tutti i
colori prendono la casa per vomitare 9
però vanno nel senso è raccapricciante
alla vista ma a di sapore c'è tutto da
ragazze dai che le crepe sono pronte
aspetta affidatogli
mettici della nutella sennò così
sbraccia e io sto bene si permette
ammazzatutti al critica ma basta da
mangiare ragazzi qui abbiamo tutti i
conti gli zuccheri nel sangue quindi
stiamo veramente vedendo i draghi io vi
invito a non provare assolutamente
questa ricetta sappiate che è molto più
comodo farci le crepe a casa
tranquillamente l'ho fatto con piacere
per celebrare questo mese
detto ciò qualora vi dovesse venire in
mente di farla attaccatevi su instagram
ma soprattutto iscrivetevi a questo
canale attivate la campanella delle
notifiche se non volete perdervi
prossimi video che ci vediamo domenica
prossima sempre le 12 con cucina buttata
ciao